I don't watch soap operas and again I
think even when people watch soap operas
all the time sometimes you end up not
realizing but kind of playing out your
own kind of soap opera you know because
you have that kind of mindset of that is
how life is but and yeah there is that
there is that fine line I suppose
between stability and boredom like me I
am a person that enjoys spontaneity and
not like routine that's one of the
reasons why I work for myself because I
don't like just like this you know same
time working every day like this mundane
kind of reality so I do think that it is
important to kind of find someone that's
also willing to kind of not just be that
you know very routine everything the
same because that does become boring